today we honor the leaders
the activists the ones who stood the
ones who dared the ones who stared
obstacles and oppression in the face and
said no
the ones who gave us hope the few who
held the line our elders whose shoulders
are wide their bats carried the weight
their hearts are full of love for this
community they are our mothers the
fathers our aunts our uncles they are
the best of the west
the ones who would knock if you book the
ones who stuck out their nets for us all
the ones who are not to be played with
when it comes to the eight the nine the
one or the six
your names are now edged in stone your
names will be carry on we are grateful
for you our leaders our activists our
mothers our fathers our aunts our uncles
our best this day belongs to you the
roots that you have planted are deeper
than any tree and today you will see
that you are now historic historic in
our hearts historic in our minds we the
west side are now full of pride because
of you as we honor truth as we honor
love as we honor courage today we honor
you the legacy thank you
wow let's give her another round of
applause
thank you so much china hudson